on a eu dans un premier temps la
fermeture des bars à 22 heures on
pouvait continuer un peu l'activité
parce que notre activité majoritaire
était la restauration maintenant on doit
fermer à 21h et comique mois
je pense que yara y en a plein qui vont
mettre la clé sous la porte
la majeure partie du personnel va partir
au chômage partiel parce qu'on n'a pas
le choix c'est pas avec 2 me dis qu'on
va pouvoir travailler ni pour voir moi
ce qui m'ennuie le plus c'est justement
c'est tout ses charges fixes je sais pas
comment on va les honorer comme les
loyers
tous les abonnements connaît et tout ça
j'ai aucune idée train que mon loyer ça
va me coûter 8 à 9 jours d'activités
voilà sur une semaine donc ça fait ça
fait plus d'une semaine donc après les
deux semaines et demie qui reste sous
trois semaines dans l'année le mois
qu'est ce que je fais j'arrive à payer
trois fournisseurs et puis et puis et
puis en fait à être déficitaire et le
soir ils mangent pendant une demi heure
les gens le soir c'est pas trop laxiste
pas qu'on le lit
le midi les gens y viennent ils mangent
d'une demi heure trois quarts mais pour
moi le sort va pas marcher pas les gens
il va rentrer à 21h chez eux et on sera
mangé chez eux je pense pas que je
vienne au restaurant 18 heures